من
الضفة الغربية إلى
بغداد، خرجوا إلى
تونس
ومدن أخرى في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة، حيث نزل الآلاف إلى الشوارع
قائلين
كفى، صور المستشفى المعمداني في غزة
كانت أكثر من أن
تتحمل مكانًا للشفاء ومكانًا
للمأوى من
لم يكن العنف العشوائي ملاذاً لأولئك المحاصرين في
هذا الجحيم على الأرض. يقول المسؤولون الفلسطينيون
إنها كانت ضربة إسرائيلية مسؤولة
عن هذه الخسارة الكارثية في الأرواح،
ونفت إسرائيل بشدة هذا الاتهام
وقالت إن الانفجار نتج عن
صواريخ فاشلة أطلقها
الطاقم الفلسطيني المتشدد.  كانت
التصريحات الإسرائيلية الصادرة عن حركة الجهاد الإسلامي بمثابة جوفاء
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين كانوا يشاهدون القنابل
تنهمر على غزة والخسائر في صفوف المدنيين.
وتزايدت يوما بعد يوم
أصدقاء إسرائيل وأعداؤها في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
سارعوا إلى إلقاء اللوم عليها وأدانوا ما
يقولون إنها مجزرة
وجريمة حرب أردنية.  ألغت دولة من أقرب
حلفاء أمريكا في المنطقة، وهي دولة يسكنها
ملايين الفلسطينيين، قمة
الزعماء العرب مع الرئيس الأمريكي التي
كانت تستضيفها يوم الأربعاء
مع تدفق الآلاف إلى الشوارع
واستخدمت قوات الأمن الغاز المسيل للدموع
لصد المتظاهرين الذين حاولوا الوصول إلى المنطقة.
السفارة الإسرائيلية في
أمان وجهوا غضبهم أيضًا إلى
المتظاهرين الأمريكيين وهم يلوحون بأحذيتهم في
الهواء للرئيس جو بايدن كما
قالوا وهم يهتفون أيها الأمريكيون اخرجوا [
موسيقى] ولي
العهد الأردني الأمير الحسين
ينشر هذه القصة على إنستغرام إسرائيل
مسؤولة عن هذا الاقتباس الضخم
لم يعد بإمكان العالم الغربي ادعاء
الأخلاق إذا استمر في هذه
المعايير المزدوجة التي كتبها منذ أيام، وقد
ظل العاهل الأردني الملك عبد الله يحذر من أن
الوضع في المنطقة قد يخرج قريباً
عن السيطرة، والمنطقة بأكملها على
شفا السقوط في الهاوية التي قد يحدثها
هذا الأمر.  إن دورة جديدة من الموت والدمار
تدفعنا نحو التهديد
بتوسع هذه الحرب، وهو أمر حقيقي، والتكلفة التي
ستجلبها هذه الحرب علينا جميعًا أكبر من أن نتحملها،
وهذا التهديد يصبح أكثر واقعية
يومًا بعد يوم مع تزايد إيران ووكلائها في
العراق.  تشير سوريا ولبنان إلى أنهما
لن تجلسا إذا استمرت إراقة الدماء،
فكل مشهد مؤلم يخرج من غزة
يجعل من الصعب احتواء الغضب الذي
يدفع الشرق الأوسط أقرب
فأقرب إلى حافة الهاوية.